hello welcome back to your GameSpot's
continuing coverage of e3 2016 we are on
the GameSpot stage talking to developers
all day long and I'm delighted to be
joined with cory VAR log sir Sony Santa
Monica you guys did a real good job of
keeping a tight lip on on God of War
what's it like to find out people out
there talking about it uh an incredible
incredible relief I did not sleep for
the four days leading up to the press
conference
partially I mean there was a little bit
of nervousness of playing to a live
orchestra right yes good playing an
early build of a game live on livestream
for millions of people to a live
orchestra because it wasn't hard enough
yeah I think it harder up the ante yeah
I know you know we're doing so much
different with this range ladies that's
totally but I was very nervous about how
it was going to be received so let's
talk about that I guess what was the
impetus behind I mean fundamentally
shifting the perspective of the camera
and then I guess the perspective of the
game where did that come from
the roots of it were kind of the
personal journey that I wanted to tell I
think coming back I said I have another
God of War in me I think and I have a
story for Kratos and it kind of was born
out of this change the shift this new
lens that I sort of see the world and
you have hid and it kind of changes the
way you see things and and how I
approached problems creatively I thought
oh there's some fascinating potential
here for what Kratos would be like if
given a second chance and stars sort of
aligned in that one right
and the the shifted camera honestly was
born of that like we want to tell a much
more intimate story we want to really
kind of get in close and initially we
took every aspect of the game broke it
apart put it on in pieces on the floor
and we're looking at each piece and the
Karo you know 12 people initially and
half and a half we loved this romantic
camera something more like we know I
think we got to do something different
and looking back at that shift from
Resident Evil 3 - Reza
hmm you want to drag himself is like you
can't make a horror game Resident Evil
game with the controllable camera yes
and lo and behold he did and I think
that's the same thing a lot of people
love the cinematic era but I think you
can get just as much intensity with that
so I guess you know you changed a lot
but what were the things that you wanted
a key forward like the sort of
fundamental things that you could not
lose in a new god of war game rifle
beginning for me it was Kratos and sort
of the history of him you know while I
want to go in and sort of reimagine all
aspects of the play experience a sort of
through line of Kratos this history that
we built the chapter 1 of his life in
the Greek era of games was what we
wanted to really maintain so that's the
really interesting storytelling can
start happening taking this character
that has made so many horrible horrible
decisions and actually gets you to care
and root for him a little bit from a
gameplay perspective there's a sort of
that accessibility that kind of pick up
and play mentality of the game so that
anybody can pick it up it's it's easy to
sort of start playing the mastery of it
comes from playing yeah so is this a
continuation of the Kratos we've already
played as or is this a new incarnation
are you talking about that yet
continuation so it is like the way I
kind of see the the mythologies is kind
of like that Hubble telescope image of
all the galaxies the Ultra Deep Field
yeah so that image shows the universe
with all of his individual galaxies each
galaxy is kind of like a representation
of a mythology you know sort of wrap
that around the earth and a given moment
all of these mythological belief systems
existed you know they all deal with the
creation myth around their region it's
just separated by geography so that well
the height of some of these mythological
beliefs there are different time periods
a lot of them kind of align with a
single point in time
even if we're not really in the biking
right come on think Norse they think
Viking but there's really this amazing
prehistory sort of the migration and
then prior to that the pre migration era
where in the Viking era they always
talked about the gods of abandon this
Thor and Loki and Odin all walk the
earth at one point
yeah and around anymore they fight for
them but they're not there and this idea
that we're at is is saying we're at a
prehistory point when the gods did
walking when when monsters were real
before they became extinct it's not cool
it's a fun space to be in because it
allows us to paint our own image of
Norse mythology as opposed to anyone
elses yeah you were saying obviously I
bet heavy you're sort of your personal
did you it you had children yourself
yeah so like this like sort of bled into
our least inspired this this new
creative shift for the game and are we
talking about Kratos asanas this is
great son himself yeah yeah where where
is the the rest of the family unit in
this situation I'm that's a very good
question that actually is a major part
of the stories kind of the answering of
that one so this thing here is kind of
just introducing the dynamic in the
relationship but in the the game you
actually find out all the information
much more this is a for me it's an
intensely personal game so much that I'm
pulling from my own life it could be
because I just lacked creativity but I
think it's really is as a writer you
always try to write what you know
so I could find more truth when you're
actually building it from something that
is nearby that is true you know I think
even high fantasy and science fiction
when it comes from a place of reality
it's relatable so many human level thing
did you have to sell it to Sony because
I mean this is one of their you know
most beloved franchises right this is
one of the feet when you think about
Sony you think about PlayStation you
think about God of War it's been there
for so long and it's been some of some
of the most enjoyable games on the
platform so I mean there's obviously a
sentiment of trust involved in there but
what was it like actually like pitching
this idea because you weren't tearing up
a lot of what you know
would make a lot of executives quite
scared yes yeah I had captain
communication with Shannon still and
when she took over the studio again we
finally got in conversations for about a
year really
toying around with this thing saying I
think I have a crazy idea and then they
immediately she was like okay I think we
could do this I started bringing people
back together getting that core team
putting a pitch together and
surprisingly you know everyone kind of
got it very quickly right you know III
think I credited to the concept that
it's it's a very simple concept
you know the idea of Kratos being able
to change because of his child yeah that
idea of how much of our selves our real
selves do we show our children and how
much of what we do changes when we know
we have a mirror reflecting our flaws
back at us right and they kind of all
were rallying around and excited and and
I think that Sony wide you know the the
whole organization really backed us
incredibly on this one and what have you
thought about the response from your
fans as well
I mean critics at least within our own
little bubble it's it's it has like you
just said actually it's it's been like
oh yeah okay this actually fits like
it's been there's a remarkable sort of
understanding right off the bat what's
it been like for like you know diehard
gotta war fans who may have been looking
for a new god of war what what have you
seen like from from those communities I
haven't seen a tongue because I've
literally been going Sunday I take a
little bit of a break here and there I
actually fell into a reaction video
rabbit hole last night okay and what's
up at like 4:00 in the morning watch it
I never even knew this existed right
yeah the idea of people taping
themselves watching something but it is
the greatest thing I have ever
experienced as a creative you sort of
pay for this stuff you may for
understanding how people react to
various things it seems sort of the true
emotional reactions they have been flow
and we watched all right watch some of
the the God of War stuff but I just kind
of watch everything I'm soaking up every
react
Vidia I could find because it was just
so incredible and then four o'clock
rolls around and I slept so it was a
very rough night but I think overall the
reaction has been amazing you know it's
I expected it to be exceptionally
polarizing I I know our fans they kind
of they trust us mm-hmm you know so even
I think in this early phase my people
are skeptical they have concerns that's
that's great I think it's fantastic to
question that and keeping it
communication with us and letting us
know the things that they're worried
about that's that I think was what makes
a better game mm-hmm Mike what was your
reaction when you saw this I'm
interested yeah it was interesting is at
first like you said the camera shift
that struck me is more of you know like
over the shoulder I'm thinking myself
it's gonna be tough trying to implement
what I assume there will be a lot of
melee combat with a controllable camera
right most the time melee games are this
third-person action you know you think
devil maker I think got a four three one
two three and ascension I thought maybe
that's interesting that they're kind of
taking this perspective with the kind of
combat I associate god of war with and
then of course this moment like
beginning of the press conference is
kind of a McCobb somber end to the demo
yeah none of hints at some themes you
might be seeing between the father and
son like a dynamic that's appealing to
me you see in the you see in a lot of
movies you see in like the road you see
it and you know right I got a real sort
of the final chapter of Red Dead
Redemption
I'm sure yeah that's right but this is a
very controversial moment for the dammit
and yeah and something like this because
I think even in the team a lot of people
work talking about doing this is how we
ended we ended big bombastic you know
monster and you know I just I've seen so
many people doing that like ending of
the monster going the black kind of
thing which is great well I think for
people to really see truly that we were
trying to do something different we had
to go crazy I got on this one yeah like
we just had to Zeke when they expected
us to zag and
it was a lot of faith I think from
everybody on the team but they kind of
all rally behind it and just made it
make it amazing another very interesting
part of that demo was seeing you sort of
take control over his song as well
during that moment it's not something we
should be preparing for like getting
used to is that sort of duality persists
throughout the game or is it more of in
that moment where he's showing him out
to fire the bow teaching is kind of an
important aspect of the game then we're
sort of passing out of knowledge from
father to son and at a time where
literally survival is like a footstep at
a time it needs a lot passed on
information to allow them to survive in
this very harsh world and so those sort
of father-son teaching moments could
just be a cinematic moment but as much
as we can we're trying to make them
interactive so that idea of in the
beginning of the game you're gonna sort
of start to nudge try to get the kid to
aim where you want him to aim you're
teaching him
but as time progresses really quickly
he's going to be a kid I got a date go
wait wait they sort of achieved not a
level of mastery but at least a level of
confidence you know because the kid is
not just a delivery system for narrative
he's not just gonna follow you around
and kind of give you information we
wanted to holistic aliy sort of connect
it to the game so there's literally a
button dedicated specifically to the kid
right and then put in concert with the
actual camera motion you kind of have
this sort of binary system that allows
you to very simply very easily wherever
you're looking at press the kid button
and the context of what you're looking
at determines whether you're going to
interact in a puzzle interact with the
environment you're going to attack an
enemy and how you sort of load out the
kid how you upgrade the kid will
actually affect what it is you're going
to do that right so it's not we never
wanted the the the son to be a a burden
he's not something you need to babysit
he is exceptionally competent in the
sense that when you are not using him he
is passively moving around the
battlefield in situations where there
are 15 enemies and two of them are
really difficult enemies 13 are just
kind of less minor enemies
he'll automatically split the
battlefield try to gain attention of
some so that you could focus on them the
other ones if you want him to do
something else sent him over there go to
those guys you know it's very simply
single button if you'll pardon the
comparison it's kind of a similar theme
I see might be a play here uncharted for
a lot of people have been talking about
how the way you look at Nathan Drake in
that game actually addresses his
character throughout the first three and
now here like you would set now Kratos
has this mirror the Sun to see himself
through is there going to be some sort
of self-examination throughout the whole
game like no yeah yeah totally he is
it's interesting because this character
that we've been so familiar with hitting
this very particular note quite often
throughout that seven games within the
the Greek era seeing him kind of start
to make different decisions seeing him
struggle with the concept of controlling
rage you know because they him godhood
is like a disease that was thrust upon
him without any choice on his part and
the side effect of that disease is rage
you know he has this God side and this
human side to things that were never
meant to co-exist together creating this
incredible amount of rage that in that
previous era of games he was the whole
yeah all the time 24/7 because he didn't
know how to be Bruce Banner and in this
game in this iteration it's like the the
son is teaching him how to be human it's
it's bringing out that sort of closeted
humanity that he stamped down for so
long but it is just struggle he fails
constantly it's like a us as parents
just children like we fail non-stop it
never stops us and if it knocks us down
it's the getting back up that's awesome
it's not that success this is that's a
suite at the end of a really hard fought
road but getting back up after each
knockdown after each failure that's
that's what you root for that's what you
care about presumably quite the
challenge is as a designer to try and
marry these like intimate moments with
I'm assuming we're going to have quite
large scale you know bombastic battles
like where we're sort of used to am i
assuming incorrectly actually is you are
assuming correctly okay we uh with this
demo we we kind of felt people know we
can do that the more I can do
bosses that we can do these kind of
grand set pieces what we need to do is
make them believe in the new Kratos and
see and sort of give him a moment of
rooting for him you know of wow I felt
something different when watching this I
didn't just feel rage and tension and
fear you know I felt something
completely different wonderful thank you
so much
Corey bar-like for coming on and then
telling us all about God of War when we
see more of it it's one of these games
that everyone's asking to like to see
more Wow seems like you you've had an e3
seems like you've probably you're
probably pretty pretty busy and pretty
tired showing people we literally are
going back to work almost immediately
after this and crushed under the weight
of being you know always behind schedule
that's gentleman you are always a year
late you know you never can get above
water but that's what makes it exciting
yeah and hopefully got a world be worth
waiting for
thank you so much come on appreciate
your time thank you so much for watching
here on the air head stage a game sports
coverage upstairs here at the Electronic
triple we are done for our second day
congratulations to everyone putting the
show together especially all the
wonderful people in the back who never
get any credit you know who you are
thank you so much you know who you are
for watching on youtube on gamespot on
twitch on Facebook probably I don't know
you're probably watching there's so many
things now I can't even take can't even
remember all of them
we are back tomorrow with a bunch more
games I'm looking at it here law
breakers are cliffy B in the morning
Delano war3 halo wars lego dimensions
loads more III feels like it's been
going on forever but it's not already
I've got one more day of this so make
sure you hit that subscribe button hit
that follow button and we'll see you
guys tomorrow morning take care you're
watching the GameSpot stage
brought to you by airheads